flugreisen gelten zu recht als das
schlimmste ökologische verbrechen
überhaupt denn die folgen für umwelt und
klima sind verheerend und so wird
weltweit fleißig an ökologischem und
günstigen treibstoff für flugzeuge
geforscht einem chinesischen
forschungsteam ist jetzt vielleicht der
durchbruch gelungen sie haben nämlich
aus pflanzenabfällen bio flugzeugbenzin
entwickelt das eine höhere energiedichte
als kerosin hat somit soll es
tatsächlich konkurrenzfähig zum
herkömmlichen hochleistungs treibstoff
seien klick zum science fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierendes 1
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpassen sie nichts los geht und haben
sich willkommen
daran gibt es nichts zu rütteln kerosin
als fossile brennstoff ist alles andere
als umwelt- und klimafreundlich deswegen
gibt es überlegungen auch in der
luftfahrt auf elektroantrieb umzurüsten
einziges problem noch die reichweite
eine andere umweltschonende alternative
zum fossilen kraftstoff könnten
biokraftstoffe seien schon jetzt testen
einige airlines biokerosin un-mission
ihn zum gewöhnlichen sprit hinzu solche
sogenannten drop in fuels erzeugen bei
ihrem verbrennen zwar auch treibhausgase
noch ihre netto bilanz könnte co2
neutral sein wenn sie aus pflanzlichem
material hergestellt werden das problem
dass bio kerosin ist fast dreimal teurer
als das normale und ist daher alles
andere als wirtschaftlich das ziel
vieler forschungsteams weltweit ist es
bio flugzeugbenzin zu produzieren dass
eine höhere energiedichte hat als
gewöhnliches kerosin
denn so könnte es denn dann auch
wirtschaftlich lohnend sein dazu der
chinesische physiker yingli der einsatz
von hochdichten flugzeug kraftstoff kann
die reichweite und nutzlast eines
flugzeugs erheblich erhöhen ohne dass
dafür größere tanks benötigt werden
bisher allerdings fehlt eine synthese
weg für diese police klo alkane aus
zellulose als ausgangsbasis des bio flug
benzins aus diesem neu entwickelten
synthese weg könnten pflanzenabfälle wie
stroh meist stengel oder sägemehl dienen
ziel der chinesischen physiker war es
diese in das gemisch aus ringförmigen
kohlenwasserstoffen umzuwandeln
das für kraftstoffe typisch ist dafür
haben die fachleute in einem ersten
schritt die zellulose aus den
pflanzenresten herausgelöst
mit der organisch chemischen verbindung
namens die kilometern haben sie die
zellulose dann in die chemische
verbindung namens 2,5 hektar medion
umgewandelt das funktioniert bei
normaler temperaturen normalen druck der
2,5 hektar region wird dann mehrmals mit
wasserstoff zusammengebracht und
reagiert so zu längeren ketten aus
ringförmigen kohlenwasserstoffen laut
dem bericht der fachleute konnten sie
durch diesem see these weg eine mehr als
70 prozentige ausbeute des
kohlenwasserstoff erreichen letztendlich
bringen katalysatoren den synthese weg
dann zu ende und polizei kam mit zwölf
und achtzehn grundstoff atomen entstehen
laut der beteiligten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
ist dieses ergebnis eine premiere
unseres wissens nach ist dies der erste
bericht über die synthese von polizei
alkan aus 2,5 examen ideen und
wasserstoff entstanden ist also einen
kohlenwasserstoff gemisch das zum einen
als hoch dichter flugzeug kraftstoff
verwendet werden kann
aber nicht nur das zudem kann das
gemisch laut der expertin expertin auch
zu herkömmlichem kerosin dazu gegeben
werden und damit umweltbilanz und
energiedichte verbessern dazu das fazit
von liebt unser biokraftstoffs kann die
co2 emissionen der luftfahrt senken weil
er aus biomasse entsteht und eine höhere
energiedichte als konventionelles
kerosin besitzt das besondere an diesem
synthese weg ist dass nicht nur die
ausgangsstoffe günstig sind sondern auch
die produktion an sich bedingt dadurch
dass nur wenige reaktionen schritte
nötig sind können die energiekosten
minimal gehalten werden somit ist der
biokraftstoff für flugzeuge laut der
fachleute eindeutig konkurrenzfähig zu
gewöhnlichem hochleistungs treibstoff
und somit auch wirtschaftlich lohnen
dennoch es gibt eine große
herausforderung denn bei dem für die
synthese notwendigen die kilometern
handelt es sich um ein giftiges und
umweltschädliches lösungsmittel und so
muss das forschungsteam noch dringend
nach einer alternative suchen die in der
lage ist die zellulose effektiv
umzuwandeln somit fehlt uns also
weiterhin eine ökologisch und
wirtschaftlich überzeugende alternative
zu kerosin aus fossilen brennstoffen
aber der weg ist jetzt klar es muss also
dringend weiter geforscht werden denn
die co2 emissionen des luftverkehrs
tragen schon
zur globalen erwärmung mit etwa fünf
prozent bei was das ganze nicht besser
macht fachleute prognostizieren ein
jährliches wachstum des luftverkehrs von
etwa 4% elektrisches fliegen vor dem
start draufklicken anschauen und clixoom
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran